what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday december the 6th the joint
is brought to you by blue chew listen
it's getting the harder dick on your
christmas list
well you're going to be having a white
christmas and new year's and valentine's
day when you order from blue chew listen
blue chew is tremendous it tastes
[__] great you can eat it on empty
stomach you can put little packages in
your pocket and it's tremendous
blue chew is an online service that
delivers the same exact ingredients as
viagra and cyalis at a fraction of a
course you can take at any time
day or night the process is simple sign
up at bluetooth.com
talk to one of our licensed medical
providers and once you're approved
you'll receive your prescription within
days the best part it's all online no
doctor's office no pharmacy no judgment
nobody knows dick well except for you
because you'll be slinging dick it ships
right to your door in a discreet package
nobody knows who gods not even the
mailman bluetooth tablets are made in
the usa usa you so you're giving
american dick you're slinging and it's
way cheaper than a pharmacy and it's the
holidays so everybody wants a good
stabbing and everybody wants a [__]
christmas present so if you need a
little boost of confidence just you
listen i don't want to when i was 22 i
wanted to just [__] for not to walk
and that's your goal
so if you can benefit from extra
confidence when it's time to perform
blue chew can help and they got a
special deal for you ready
try blue chew for free with promo code
joey j-o-e-y
just pay the fin five dollars for
shipping that's blue chew promo code
joey to receive your first month gratis
free and as always i want to thank
bluechu for sponsoring the joint you
understand me the joint is also brought
to you by the animals
freeze pipe listen if you've got someone
on your holiday list who loves all the
newest gadgets and gizmos they're gonna
love freeze pipe that bung that gives
you an extra smooth high every time
plus it gets you stoned to the [__]
gills the name of the pipe you're
looking at right now i don't even know
what the name of the [__] pipe is
it's beautiful okay it's the bond this
thing they should just call it the devil
that's it smoking weed doesn't have to
hurt your lungs with freeze pipe you'll
get a nice cold hit every time and
here's how it works the pipe comes with
a detachable chamber you freeze
beforehand when you're ready to see the
devil
the smoke passes through the frozen part
and it cools down the smoke as you
inhale it's like putting ice cubes in a
bun just [__] better who knows who
pissed on that [__] snow
god knows it's non-toxic it freezes
faster than water and it stays frozen
longer freeze pipe cools down the smoke
by hundreds of degrees whether you hit a
pipe the bubbler the bung or the dab
they got you covered if you can't smoke
from it freeze pipe makes it okay so do
me a favor cut this [__] for the
holidays
go to freezepipe.com and press and code
joey and get 10 off your first order
this is a christmas probably listen it
says if you know somebody special you
know who that special person is
you [__] take care of yourself go
to freezepipe.com
press and code joey and get 10 off your
first order get a bomb pipe or a [__]
bubbler that's freezepipe.com
pressing code joey and save 10 percent
you're going to the murky waters for
[__] christmas and
the joint is also brought to you by
draftkings tremendous this week you got
the ufc you got college football
tonight you got buffalo against new
england a tremendous [__] game better
dollar you win 203 credits by going to
draftkings sportsbook and pressing code
joey and that's it and that's that let's
get this party [__] started it's
monday i got things to do and so do you
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday december the 6th a beautiful
[__] day to be alive here on
joey's joint abx
coming through for the holiday season
with the capsules of [__] deck i
won't have any lonely nights
you know what i'm saying you're never
lonely with abx 100 milligram capsules
and if you get the 200s forget about it
you won't be lonely you'll have people
talking to you you could talk back to
them it's okay we won't tell nobody it's
just a [__] another saturday night
here at the diaz compound what's
happening you bad [__] i'm
feeling great
i'm looking great jiu jitsu's first week
was great
it's a [__] drill class i don't give
a [__] i go down there
i get to jump up and down and do some
hip escapes and some jumping jacks and
then some guy lays on me they teach you
a throw
the move in the [__] submission you
practice it and you go home after 45
minutes but look what it's done for me
it's better than sitting at home staring
at the wall asking yourself what did i
go wrong you know what i'm saying i
can't [__] stand sitting at home
anymore but it was a great week this
week we had some [__]
interesting goddamn events in the
country this week that
i always [__] uh sit there and
scratch my head when i read about
something
and it had like i could compare myself
to that story that's how i do with those
things
like a [__] 15 year old little [__]
shoots down the [__] school did you
see the picture of that [__]
what he looks like
that kid had some [__] problems
listen i got some problems but that
little [__] kid at 15 or 16 got some
problem you see a picture that little
yeah they had [__]
hunt the [__] parents down the
[__] and i am ecstatic
i am listen man
way before i was a parent i remember
during the columbine thing
uh columbine the [__] florida
shooting i was like this shit's gotta
stop parents this was way
before i was a [__] parent that i was
like wow
guys i was a broken [__] kid i found
my mother on the floor
and i hated [__] god okay when you
have a beef with yourself you have some
mental issues that's one thing i had no
mental issues i had something worse
i had a beef with [__] god what does
that mean joy that you had a beef with
god well
if i saw a cat i'd shoot it with a
[__] bb gun if i saw an ant i stepped
on it if i saw
a [__] dog i wanted to hit it with
the car i mean that's anger against the
world that's when you're lashing the
[__] out
you know and i had a [__] big time
problem with it i haven't even copped a
half the things i did because of
stupidity and anger i can't even count
the amount of things i did but and all
that [__] mental war i had going on
with myself at 16
17 and 18 this is what i compare this to
i go [__] i never
never had even a thought two thoughts
never entered my mind doing a swan dive
off to george washington which is always
[__] easy to do
or take a gun and go in and shoot my
[__] classmates
i never even [__] thought of that
i never even thought about shooting
anybody i was maybe like 21.
you know what i'm saying i mean yeah
when you get older you think of shooting
people and fantasies somebody says
something to you somebody picked on you
you're like [__] i walked away from that
guy and i should have shot him in the
[__] leg i mean these are the things
you start thinking when you have that
hatred in your heart i don't know what
this little [__] [__] hated i have
no [__] idea what made him do
what he does but i mean listen
everybody's going down on this i mean
the school
went after the parents to cover their
ass but
there's going to be parents that sue
that [__] school for letting that kid
go home
they left them in the they didn't let
them go home i'm sorry i screwed up the
facts
they let him stay at school he had done
a note he had done a note of him
shooting a teacher
like with a stick man and all this [__]
blood i i don't know exactly what he
said i know it's [__] [__] and he
[__] took it
they called his parents his parents came
and by the time they asked him for the
note he had altered the
note so right then and there me as a
teacher and as a safety get this kid out
there he made the right call by
asking him to go to therapy in the next
48 hours that was a great call
but you know what the second best call
was get this [__] out of there
they let him sit in school and then he
shot those kids
and i got my heart goes out to that
[__] kid that
[__] ran after him and
lost his life as a [__] hero i mean
there's some great stories coming out of
michigan
but it's a really [__] sad situation
that
i can't figure like i'll sit there for
hours and go well you know i'll go for a
ride or something and that's how i break
down things you know now that i'm not
getting high in the daytime well we're
changing that [__]
abx came through like a [__]
tremendous
abx came through again with the capsules
and they came through with these
[__] loud and clear diamond i
mean [__] tremendous [__] and you
guys know i don't like vapers but you
know what
i tried to yesterday didn't do much to
me like i got me a little high made me
want to get a slice of pizza
so i said [__] and i'll start hitting
these on a daily basis you know
like i said i'm not getting high at
night and i'm kind of enjoying it but
who gives a [__] let's back to the
[__] michigan retards
those [__] idiots because no listen
if you're listening to this podcast
right now and you have a child that
could have been your child
i don't want you to [__] walk around
going my child no
but think about it when you really that
could be a school in california
that could be a school in new jersey
that could be a [__] school anyway
you're a parent you're at work you're
hustling you're not really thinking
about
that situation you get that call that
there's a school shooter your [__]
heart must drop your [__] everything
you know
everything will stop this kid when you
look at the kid
you look at the mother and you look at
the father holy [__] listen i got
problems like i said before but you
could tell these guys withdrew four
thousand dollars
there's just so many kinks in this the
father bought the kid the gun
the kid took it to school you know he
posted on social media
and this has been something that's
getting worse and worse in this country
i mean every [__] you know
and like i said i think about i can't
lie to you i thought about this [__]
before i had a kid like i would sit
there and go what the [__] is going on
with these little bastards
like i'm very happy that
there's cops at my daughter's school
there's always a cop there there's a cop
a security force that drives around like
when you ask what i do people always go
you know they just ran a [__] uh
a uh a commercial here before the
election november 4th this is you know
the way they're going to take down
murphy and uh
again i'm not political i don't give a
[__] who won let's make a [__]
asterisk right there i don't want people
going joey but you vote i didn't vote
for nobody i'm a felon so stop it but
before the [__] murphy thing came
down it was interesting they would say
uh you know they would had a commercial
of them asking phil murphy about taxes
and phil murphy replied listen if tax is
an issue
jersey is not your [__] state and
people got pissed off at that but i'm
gonna tell you something i pay 11 tax
here or something [__] outrageous
i don't mind i don't mind
because they clean up my leaves they
come pick them up once a month during
the fall i have a garbage pick up
my my my wife had some [__] issue
with mercy mercy's got anxiety
mercy went to the school nurse jesus
christ they [__] called here they
sent all type of paperwork i mean they
were just great people i couldn't
[__] believe it and then the fact
that when you go to that school you're
not getting in there
you're not you're not getting in there
guys i got to be honest do i like that
yes and no it's got its pros and it's
got its cons i don't think you could
slip a gun in there you know they break
them up they got what they got enough
[__] schools around here they got one
school across the street from another
school
you know i mean it's [__] crazy here
they got tons of [__] schools but one
thing is right i met the guy at the pool
this summer that does security at one of
the schools and he was telling me that
protocols and i was like what
he just kept going on how they have all
that [__] covered they got a machine gun
there to shoot some [__] [__] that
shows up or whatever they're prepared
they're just prepared
do i know accidents happen yes that's
not the end-all be-all
but does it make me feel a little bit
more comfortable throughout the day yes
knowing that there's a cop there my
daughter doesn't need to see that
children never need to see that
i'm so happy they closed the [__]
school afterwards
they're
scared in michigan that there's going to
be more retaliation at the [__]
schools that's no way to [__] live
that's no way to [__] live you got to
put these [__] kids down jack we got
a [__] up kingdom and listen i
appreciate
you know i get therapy i understand that
i live it
but there's some people that better help
can't help you know what i'm saying and
that kid
better help can't help that [__] kid
i don't care how many video screens he
does
or how many video sessions you can see
when somebody's [__] damaged goods
and you're like going joey who the [__]
are you to say that i was damaged goods
and i know the road to come back i know
what damaged goods means it means where
your mind is not [__] uh you know
when you're thinking about killing
people you know 1988 between the cocaine
my pain and all the [__] i was
walking around there for a few months
thinking it would be nice to shoot
somebody in the [__] leg i'm not
gonna lie to you and when i kidnapped
that [__] dude i had the opportunity
to shoot them both
and i went out in my car and i got my
gun and i thought i was [__] don
johnson on miami vice and i'll tell you
what it's not that i chickened out it's
that i have a value for life and i know
that when you murder somebody you're
going into a complete different realm of
life that you're not gonna come back
from that stays with you the rest of
your [__] life and it's like it could
either be like a shark effect you know
uh you you bite one time and now you get
to taste the [__] blood and you don't
stop again or so i wasn't in the
business of even
they weren't threatening me the only
threat they had to me that they were
going to testify against me
that's not a threat it was a 50 50
chance one of the idiots testified
against me so it wasn't a bad deal but
i wouldn't i didn't want to make a bad
situation worse
that day that that was a bad situation
at one i went to rob that kid at 118 and
i knew by 140 that this was a
knucklehead [__] move
but the wheels were in motion it was too
[__] you couldn't stop it you know
you just couldn't stop it at the time
and now i was all in but after i saw his
face
after that tidwell did what he did to me
by [__] trying to rob me
listen both of them deserve to [__]
get shot but
i'm happy that i was strong enough at
the time to think about and go this
would have just made the situation worse
and that was the end of me wanting to
kill anybody
for years i walked around going the
first guy that disrespects me or beats
me in a drug deal especially in bold i
had a [__] uh chip on my head i was
like the first guy that says anything to
me i'm just gonna [__] shoot him i
drive around with a gun i almost ended
up shooting my ex-wife's boyfriend i'll
tell you what i don't that's why
i have a gun now it's hidden i don't
flaunt it i don't practice shooting you
know when i was a kid i would shoot i
didn't i thought about where my head
went when i had a pistol and what a
pistol was for
and when the pandemic started hitting
l.a you know look what's going on in l.a
now look what's going on in l.a now so i
guess i was [__] wrong about l.a
i guess i was wrong when i told
everybody listen
pack your bags
today this is not a uh
this is not a [__] uh a deal where
you know i'm gonna put work for a month
i'm gonna work for six months and put
away money
and in six months i'll decide where i'm
gonna go you ain't gonna have the chance
in [__] l.a
you look what's going on in l.a they
just guys for you [__] that
don't know
i'll tell you what just happened friday
[__] night i don't know if you guys
knew i had a podcast office
and it was on cumpston street and i also
had a house on clemson street i didn't
own it i rented it
that's why i got the office on custom
street
because i could walk to the [__]
office that was uh that was uh
that was tremendous
i'm sorry i'm taking a breather i've
been [__] advised not to drink water
on the mic no more but you try talking
for eight minutes and not being thirsty
when i leave here my throat's like a
[__] grape okay my uncle's [__] uh
uncle uncle van
florentine said something to me then a
couple other people said something to me
i don't give a [__] i'm just trying to
be a political you know i'm trying to be
a nice [__] guy here what we talking
about before i was interrupted with
myself here
[Music]
the [__] thing in michigan the thing
in michigan you should do
no because it was [__] [__] you
had a house yeah i had the house in
compton and i had the the office in
cumstone then
the baby was born the landlords got
weird so we moved but i still kept an
office in cumston
before i left guys i don't know if some
of you guys listening to the church
i don't know if you guys know what i was
talking about here when i was saying
that uh
that
i saw the guy hit the guy with the 4x4
at the train station
i saw the [__] hooker the white dude
punched a hooker in the [__] head
i saw a couple things that just
it it was too quick
like it went from
everybody was smoking dope and viva
california and all this [__]
just somebody getting hit by a 4x4 not a
2x4 not a new chuck not a [__] piece
of wood but a four by four guys it's the
thick one four by four just to put your
hands around it's like holding a [__]
you ever see a chick in a porn where
she's got a black [__] and a [__]
hand and that's what a foot even a big
white dude even if i [__] put a 4x4
it would just be my hand look at these
gorilla hands that i got and it would be
[__] hard to carry a four by four
it's like when they have that uh you
ever see those those little white chicks
with the [__] they got like blonde
streaks in their hair and they're
sucking a black [__] and the black [__]
looks like a tuba and they're sticking
in their [__] mouth it's just crazy
this [__] and this dude was no
[__] six foot six dude this is a
little skinny white dude that probably
smoked crack a half hour before and he
still had the [__] strength to pick
up a 4x4 and clock three or four [__]
people when i saw that you got to think
about that i could if that was a fist
fight it wouldn't have bothered me do
you understand me if it was too puerto
rican stabbing each other i would have
just kept driving but this was a white
dude with a warrior's vest on no t-shirt
underneath
just clocking [__] at a bus
stop i'm watching these people just go
down somebody is behi you know like what
makes people do that [__] i knew right
then and there when i got home i go
listen
we're packing up bags and we're getting
the [__] out of here
okay and my wife and then my wife
started saying stuff and then one night
i went to smoke with my friend sophia
behind the ymca we'd go back there
[__] three nights a week during a
pandemic she'd sit in her car i'd sit in
my car and we'd just talk [__] and smoke
the [__] number and then we started
sitting with each other because nobody
was getting covered it was all a [__]
scam back there
so [__] i heard a gunshot go off
the gunshot it was like on the [__]
corner we talked for a little bit
a little bit more and then i went home
and when i walked in my wife goes where
the [__] were you
they just shot somebody on [__]
magnolia and lancashire and i go dawg it
sounded i could hear that
all those little events going from zero
to [__] 60 and doing a pandemic
like not even this was the pandemic
started march
everything shut down march 13th
this was already in june i was seeing
this [__] so what happened
friday [__] on clemson
right up the block from the office that
i loved and you guys you know eight
years we were there
a guy went to melrose to eat dinner
came home sat in this house and at three
in the morning they kicked in this front
door a home invasion and they [__]
robbed them
you know where it was guys if you go
to office you get out of the office with
your car on foot
you walk 100 yards you probably hit my
old house and then you walk another 100
yards and you probably need to hit
another street i don't know what that
street was called it went like if this
if this street was going south to north
this one was going east to west so i
don't really know the name of it i'm
sorry
a guy right there it was two and a half
blocks from that office
that's north hollywood studio city
that's not good guys
that's not [__] good all those people
that are there and i don't know it's
okay oh they're cleaning it up a little
bit sure cause misery loves company
nobody's gonna tell you that l.a sucks
right who the [__] is gonna look in the
face and tell you man don't come here no
they got all those [__] scumbags are
gonna go yeah come on out here or
whatnot so right now they just go they
tell you not to go on melrose
[__] we grew up on melrose 91210
right five little white kids [__]
each other they had herpes
they had [__] all that [__] right we
[__] grew up on that if you're my age
i know i did i you know i didn't watch
it religiously but you're watching
you're like there's six kids they're
rich they got trust funds and that's not
in coke [__] great neighborhood i
[__] love it sign me up too bad i
don't have parents you know what i'm
saying i mean
so
they uh
melrose that's what it represented you
know how many great times i had on
melrose the time i went to vegas where i
bought that suit to open up for tim
allen was on melrose doug stanhope took
me down i mean melrose is just a fun
little [__] place me and ari used to
go to a chinese place those combo dip
places that pour all the noodles in and
oh my god we used to have a piss on maro
salz was on melrose the improv was on
melrose how many nights were zion
melrose crossing the street with the
[__] uh dos manos gumi's guys
they would bring down [__] uh
bongs bigger than this [__] here bigger
than freeze pipe that well what do you
call those things because they have one
too not a doubler yeah the dabber the
bubble the dabber they would bring down
dabbers the size of that me [__] lee
next time i have leon we'll talk about
the night with the [__] goomies or
models we're on melrose and there's
eight nine people two of the gummies are
monos and we're [__] sparking those
things that they said
the [__] dabs yeah it was like a
blowtorch right on [__] melrose i'm
like holy [__] we're gonna go to jail
that was the beginning of the [__]
end and i'll never forget hitting those
three dabs and it felt like my lungs
were crushing it was at that moment at
the improv that i decided this that
business ain't for uncle joey i i can't
bring a blowtorch to the house i can't
have this [__] in my
in house
it's like the damn [__] no he sent me
another one that's like the dab [__]
let's try another one of these [__]
nice i'm feeling [__] question you
know what i'm saying
it's monday morning december 6
[__] come on strap on a pad a
month is here we got 24 20 something
[__] i don't even know how many
[__] days 19
shoplifting days till [__] christmas
you know i heard john lennon the other
day in the car already and so is this
christmas i think on friday i was
driving back from jiu jitsu and i heard
john lennon it brought a tear to my it
was a [__] beautiful day but i'm
excited guys
2022 is gonna be our [__] year and i
hope you're thinking the same way listen
2021 and 2020
that was something that we couldn't
[__] control that's it it's over but
now you could do whatever the [__] you
want
i don't know the numbers are raising but
you could still [__] make it happen
you just got to do it [__] smart
i've been getting out there a lot more
you know listen man it's over
this is a [__] new ominous code
whatever that came from
i'm a crop whatever the [__] came from
africa listen you know what
the devil was born in africa as long as
you [__] know you know what you
didn't see the [__] exorcist that's
the devil the devil was born in [__]
africa he vacations in los angeles
that's why la is so [__] up okay i
don't even know how i was going with
this
that vapor pen does have some [__]
kick i got to refer this to people holy
[__]
loud and clear this is the diamond
[__] series
my boys over there [__] they wanted
to hook me up for the holidays beside
abx we're gonna do a 200 milligram
capsule together
the joey dear's [__] capsule of death
you're gonna look like jose aldo giving
that dude the eye of death last night
jose aldo got into a tremendous fight on
saturday night and in the fourth round
the kid clocked him in the [__] eye
the puerto rican kid clocked him in the
[__] eye and his eye
was completely locked
he was fighting a dude with one eye but
the way his eye looked like you could
have a pretty eye but when you get hit
in this eye
and this eye gets [__] locked on your
right eye the left eye got a little
sharp it's like he got hit in the eye
but he did a line of coke on the left
[__] nose and it went straight to the
eye this eye was alive and [__]
kicking it was looking at everything
you ever you even see that you ever see
the [__]
the adam's family where people would
walk by and uncle fester would follow
him with the eye
that's like aldor was with that one and
trust me i love jose aldo i'm not
goofing on him i'm just adding some
[__] humor to the situation here jose
aldo's [__] wanna he looked like that
all i kept thinking about was i swung by
judas priest off
off a hell bent for leather i got a
contact on you i have i i knew he was
[__] looking at that [__]
aldo won i don't know how he survived it
he's a [__] 40 year old savage
he held the guy down he did what he had
to do but when that [__] eye was
alive and kicking
and he had that eyeball oh my god and
listen
bell bet for leather in the uk was
released as killing machine and that's
one of the songs on that album it goes
right into the [__] killing machine
then i've got a contact on you and all
sudden you see that [__] there was a
girl in high school who had a glass eye
and all the kids used to sing that to
her we got a contact on you she used to
get pissed off but what are you going to
do
it was the past nobody kicked her in the
chins you know what i'm saying so
that's the truth everybody getting there
some kid bullied my daughter last week
he put [__] uh
a tremendous week last week at the dia's
residence some [__] kid bullied mercy
on monday
mercy came home came right downstairs
like that i need to talk to he was
classic
she's like he did this he put he threw
my hat
and you know i don't want to get in
trouble i got mercy there's no trouble
when you're defending yourself
there's no trouble that's the only
trouble that you don't defend yourself
that you don't stick up for yourself
i go kick him in the [__] nuts
as hard as you can
you know but don't let him [__] he's
two grades ahead of her guys what am i
supposed to do [__] make her become a
wallflower no she's no lay down sally
i'm not going to raise labino lay down
sally
i want her to get on that [__] bus
and stick up for herself so little
friends stuck up for her then the next
day both of them stuck up to the guy and
now they separated them the kids in the
back of the bus
and the two girls are in the front
living like doctors and i told her you
got to stand up for yourself who gives a
[__] just go for it if you get in
trouble i'm not going to be mad at you
because you stuck up for yourself i
never will
that was my problem when i was a kid i
didn't [__] stick up for myself you
got to stick up for yourself who gives a
[__] what they think or how they feel
you know so she's a lot better now but
i told her i said you know if he hits
you just call him a [__] [__]
because he won't hit girls you know and
that night jimmy florentine came home
with his kid and she's at the table
eating she's like if he touches me
tomorrow i'm gonna call him a [__] and
even jimmy's kid [__] felt it up my
wife's eyes opened up my wife pulled me
aside you can't tell that [__] joey you
know
she's just a little [__] girl but
what am i supposed to do i gotta teach
her to [__] defend herself you know
it's tough it's really [__] tough
trying to
i never knew i would even utter these
words but it's very tough to raise a
child today what i can't tell them what
i you know i don't want my daughter to
[__] go out there and sound like a
bigot so at the house i
i don't say dick no more you know i
decided that
all this [__] that happened this last
year it's true people needed to clean up
their houses a little bit but they had
to clean up their houses
if you're gonna go out and then go in
the house and talk to your kids
about what's going on out there or
you're gonna you have to clean up your
act at the house
if i'm gonna come in the house and just
go can you believe those bmf guys those
[__]
you can't say that [__] in front of your
kid that's what i decided even though i
think that i'm not saying to bmf people
or chinese but i'm not saying nothing
what i'm trying to say to you is that
you know
i don't even know what i'm trying to
[__] say all i know it's monday
december the [__] 6th and we're just
trying to put the [__] pieces
together here but it's the truth i'm
just trying to
who knows what i'm trying to do i'm just
trying to be a responsible guy but i
remembered that
the santoria guy said that to me goes
you got to clean up your act outside but
most importantly you got to clean up
your act in your house and how you feel
behind what you say behind closed doors
because i've always been one to feel you
know i could see when somebody's [__]
a hypocrite
i could see when somebody's talking out
of their mouth and you can tell the
people that will tell you whatever you
need to see to your face
but behind closed doors they're saying
look at these [__] spikes taking our
jobs at the border you know
i know a couple people like that that
you talk and they can't they can't help
themselves but you know the problem with
this country is they're like mexicans
said okay the problem why you're a
[__] bum is because some mexican came
in that couldn't
talk english and he took your job that's
why you're mad at them because they have
a [__] will to live more than you
they have a desire to live more than
[__] you that's why you call them
respect that's not [__] fair say that
you're a [__] mutt that doesn't want
to do the job and you don't want to
welcome the [__] challenge
you know what i'm saying that that's the
[__] truth of the matter here so
sometimes i look at it that way i look
at it that way like oh
i get it this [__] sucker you know
but i had a i have a friend that i talk
to once a month i love him i grew up
with him
but he blames all the problems of this
world on spanish people i can't have
that
i can't add that
that's a [__] cop out in my world you
know what i'm saying that's a cop-out
i can't have that that's thinking
that'll [__] ban you forever whatever
you feel about the [__] mexicans that
are taking your job whatever do you want
to really do that job look how many jobs
we have open right now you can get a job
doing anything you could up higher now
you can do whatever the [__] you if you
really want to do it there's a job out
there for you how do i know i get 2 000
[__] emails a day from zip recruit
and let me know they got me a job as an
inside salesman at some llc it's [__]
crazy out there and the salaries they're
paying are [__] crazy while you're
sitting there with a college degree not
doing anything
i don't get it i don't [__] get it
even right now they're hiring you with a
if you were a sharp kid in high school
right now you could probably get a job
making 100 grand a year a sharp kid in
high school you didn't have to go to
college let's say you played the piano
in high school and you [__] jumped up
and down and you helped put the av
equipment away you got a hundred
thousand job waiting for you you're
smart a lot of other people that are
[__] out there they don't even know
what [__] audio visual material is
neither do i i don't know that [__] i
don't even know if that should exist
today that's how you're right with
technology i don't think they bring out
a screen anymore on a projector
well they have different kinds of [__]
yeah but i i don't think i think like i
went to some guy's house he was showing
me a movie one day
and his [__] screen was as uh
projector was the size of a [__]
iphone and he put it on a table with a
book and all of a sudden we're watching
a movie on that thing so god knows what
the technology's changing you know i'm
saying but
the main thing i wanted to talk about
was
what made mike decard this week that
michigan [__] thing oh my god
when they arrested the parents listen i
know a lot of parents
breathe the sigh of [__] relief
that is [__]
counter
productive right there i [__] loved
it the other thing i want to talk to you
guys about is chris cuomo
[__] they fired the whole cuomo clan
i don't even know what people were
talking about i saw on the internet that
they cnn fired fredo
i'm like who's [__] fredo what the
[__] who's fr i kept saying that
did people go after him for that they
called a freighter yeah because he got
pissed about it or something oh okay
yeah fredo's on cnn
dog that is listen just get just get
this through your head
in the new state of america when they
want you they [__] want you
you know i'm again i'm not political i
just listen to what's going on and it
makes me [__] laugh
from the minute i got off the [__]
plane last august 19th all i heard was
how cuomo and [__]
general murphy whatever the governor
murphy [__]
put all people back and all the homies
and killed them i'm not laughing about
that i'm laughing about general murphy
that i cracked the stupid joke you know
i'm black brother though right i don't
know who the [__] it was i don't know
who put the old government right but no
no no it was cuomo and it was it wasn't
[__] poor fredo on cnn
it was uh
it was governor cuomo who supposedly
brought
old people back into old people places
and they died from coven and murphy this
is this is what everybody complained
about i don't have time to worry about
this [__] i'm sorry
if it's true and to the families but
i don't know
so
when i found out about all that stuff
i'm like i don't know when they started
turning on them for the sexual
allegations
i'm like you know here we got an
old-school situation when they want
somebody to [__] out of here and they're
going to get them out no matter what
they're going to find something a ticket
from 1982 a [__] stewardess who he
[__] in the ass i mean the guy's got
nipple rings so that tells you he's a
[__] freak right governor cuomo
chelsea and then he covered his ass he's
a smart dude he's a smart predator
because he covered his ass chelsea
handler hit on him
before [__] joe coy she hit on him
and like during the pandemic she's like
governor cuomo you're handsome how about
we get together he's like no chelsea oh
my god he played it off like he don't
need [__] but little did we find out
two weeks later he's sending dick pics
and giving out foot rubs and [__]
these [__] alligator you know
it's always something now now they're
going after listen i'm gonna tell you
guys something this is my opinion i just
tell you in my opinion
i was in hollywood for 23 [__] years
and i met a lot of con men i met a lot
of [__] artists i meant sexual
deviants i met them all
jeff garland is a good guy
i woke up yesterday morning to some
yahoo [__] about jeff garland that
the greenberg is getting [__]
the goldbergs i don't know the
greenbergs the goldbergs
my daughter hangs out with a goldberg i
like her a lot she's a great kid she
really is she's a great kid she comes
over once a month they go swimming they
play softball together she's a good kid
but the goldbergs on
a abc the show that callum was on
is getting accused and i'm not saying
anything bad about calum just saying
that when i looked at the article i read
it
just to see if they were going to
mention brian cowan you know what i'm
saying because they're going to throw
them into the [__] stew but no it had
to do with jeff garland and just
that hr had to call him in three times
and [__] that he goes on the set and he
said something like you know my vagina
hurts and he laughed at it you know and
that he's an extreme hugger
what's an extreme hugger they make him
wear tighty weighties on the show like
that's what he wears
um
the 80s people did come home take their
pants off and jump in the [__]
cocaine pool of death or they just
jumped in the backyard or whatever the
[__] they were doing
now listen i i i known that guy i knew
him
i knew his ex-wife his ex-wife always
took care of me she was a partner at a
casting director firm so when i would go
in there
she would read me and then we'd talk
about
her husband
her partner was always like was a great
casting director i forget what her name
is oh my god i know her phone number
i don't know her name because we were on
the phone
all the time this lady that was also
friends with joshua i told you guys a
couple months ago that i did a
commercial one of the best pieces of
work i ever [__] did was a commercial
forever ready battery
i got a call one day from this great
woman
and she goes can you do a commercial for
me i'm not even gonna [__] audition
you she goes i know you could do it but
it's just the weather you want to do it
and then
she gave me a shot listen to this
commercial guys
me and some other hump
are dragging a [__] dude into the
woods
and we can't see
so i tell the guy hold on dummy i go
behind the car and i start the car and i
put the headlights on
and the headlights we throw the guy on
the floor and it gives us an opportunity
to dig a hole
you know let's believe let's pretend
it's like a place like pine barrens
where they took uh the chicken from the
sopranos let's you know whatever it's
just a wooded area
so we go in this wooded area and we dig
we dig and we dig a hole long enough and
we throw the guy in we cover the hole
and we look at each other and we're like
hey
somebody put on the radio you know what
i'm saying so when i go to put sinatra
on the car battery's that and an ad
comes up and it says
sears ever ready bad you know to die
hard it would never happen to you with
the die hard i thought the commercial
was brilliant
i thought the whole uh
campaign was brilliant
and i'm like holy [__] i'm gonna be able
to buy a car like i was like i just i
needed like a three thousand dollar car
at the time and she made it
possible she was like hey man if you
shoot this it's a national blah blah
blah
it's a spec commercial what a spec
commercial means is they're going to pay
you a little bit of money
the company likes it but they don't know
if they really love it and they just
want to do like a test
so they paid me a little money i didn't
get rich it was like a daily fee
and uh they didn't pick it up ever ready
sears didn't pick it up i was pissed off
whatever but it doesn't matter this girl
put me in 20 of those things
so every time i would have to go to her
office i would see
jeff garland's wife and i would talk to
jeff garland's wife and then one day
she's like [__] it you don't know jeff
like this is 15 years ago i'm talking
about when i was struggling she
connected me with all this work and
she's like you don't know jeff i hook
you up with jeff and i met jeff and jeff
was always a sweetheart to me at the
store the only uh i never really worked
with him on the road i went to them at
the store but listen i could i could get
a better grip of you i could better i
could get a better read on you of who
you are at the store
than if i see you on the road when we're
on the road our heads are in different
places you know we want to get the [__]
home
you know you got [__] blow in your
pocket you want to do there's a chick
that wants to sniff your nuts there's
always something so you i don't really i
never really
connected with people like if i if i was
in houston and there was three comedy
clubs and mikey
i was at the laptop and mike was at the
last spot
if i got off early i would take a car
over have one of the other comedians
drive me if i liked mikey like if i knew
mike we knew each other like we were
both from
i don't know like if me and mikey both
came up at gotham comedy club in the
city but i never got to see him but i
heard from chris bazilli the manager
that great guy that
uh
mike was a good guy and i was a good guy
now we think alike or whatever you guys
should talk because there's not you know
whatever i would go over and say hello
to mike but i wouldn't hang out with it
because i had to go back and do my own
cocaine why am i going to share my
cocaine with you so i would just meet
you
and go back but i always knew that that
wasn't
solid
for me to really like get to hang out
with you i either have to spend the
weekend with you work with you or see
you at the store at the store after you
get on stage you know where are you
going i'm going to the main room i'm
going to the original room i'll see you
you don't even say i'll see you outside
later i'll see you later and then we
stumble on the bar how was your set how
was your set they sucked i sucked
in all my interactions with jeff
i never saw nothing negative
the same way i never saw nothing
negative with brian cowan all that [__]
that happened
i saw brian with with
chicks that wanted to be there i didn't
see anybody with a chick that had a
handcuff on and a [__]
noose and she's like let me go i'm
getting dragged into the comedy store i
didn't see none of that [__] so i don't
know what's going on with greg i don't
even know if that's why
they're looking at him for some sexual
[__] but it said inappropriate behavior
what the [__] is an appropriate behavior
anymore
what is the threshold of an appropriate
[__] baby i have no [__] idea
and this is why i'm staying out of the
[__] mess because
i never showed
the big problem with me is what i'm
gonna say
you know that there's somebody who
pulled me aside maybe three weeks ago
and she said one of the moms
said that
you were talking to a husband you said
something a little bit
dirty yeah
that's what i do he didn't complain
about it but to some people i know that
i might sound a little [__] off from
time to time that doesn't mean i'm a
[__] pervert or i'm looking at but
you just say i i know what i said to
the [__] lady at the park about three
months ago there was a lady i'm not
gonna tell you what she did
she was a big woman like bigger than me
you know she's just a chick that's like
[__] pushing 270. and she had like
tight shorts on him i looked at my
friend i go can you imagine what her ass
smells like it was like 90 degrees you
know
i grew up on that [__] i would tell it
to my brother all the time that was uh
and and mike running i would always look
at them and go can you imagine whatever
ass must smell like you know 90 degrees
it's humid out and some chicks eating a
[__] bag of doritos and their ass is
bigger than mine you know you got to
crack a joke from time to time you got
to have a good time here
but all in all listen guys i
i'm 100 better i feel better i look
better
uh
i was in a rut for a while i didn't know
what i wanted to do
but eventually between journaling
exercising walking
interacting with you [__] i've
come to my conclusions of what i want to
do and i feel a lot [__] bad it's
december 6. i just want to finish this
tapering which comes to an end december
[__] 11th
so we got another week of [__]
tapering i don't even feel it anymore
i'm moving the [__] on like i said to
you i'm looking at 2022 to be my
breakout year
you're like joey what do you got going i
got nothing going on i got a book coming
out and my balls are getting bigger by
the day and longer by the day that's all
i got going on [__]
but i'm still gonna rock here i don't
know we're gonna [__] change it up
we're gonna add guests in this
[__] we're gonna do something
but 2022 i can't tell you how excited i
am about it i can't tell you how excited
how quick i want this [__] holiday to
be over with i love the holidays i can't
wait for christmas to come and we jump
up and down and have a good time but i'm
really looking forward to 2022 and i
hope you are too i'm writing goals again
i'm [__] uh
you know making little predictions the
[__] book is
fantastic
i tell you
i'm not a writer i'm just a [__] uh
i'm a storyteller
and that's what i did i took all these
things i outline them at night and i
tell her the story the next day
last week we were on the phone five days
writing this book
so we're moving right along i'm very
proud of myself you know for months
i thought i was just [__] dying but
little did i know i was putting nfps
together
getting stronger [__] selling reefer
selling [__] uh writing a book and
getting healthy and now with the joining
of [__] uh
you know bjj i added that but i got to
tell you one other thing that really
[__] helped me
put it together and that was better out
better help is uh
[Music]
better help is online therapy it wants
you to know the truth that some stigma
is around mental health if anybody had a
stigma about mental health it was your
[__] uncle joey guys
i didn't know what the [__] uh was going
on with me and i always thought i never
really could talk to somebody but i got
into a [__] bind i got into a pickle
and uh a couple people suggested i
talked to therapy i i was like i don't
know
i don't [__] know because right as
soon as you say 30 people think you're
[__] crazy but therapy doesn't mean
there's something wrong with you it just
means that you recognize
that we're all [__] human and we all
got emotions and we need to learn to
control them and how to [__] not
avoid them all right therapy is a tool
to utilize before things get worse i
didn't know about that
now i love it if i would have known how
much i needed therapy i would have gone
through therapy when i was at
doing comedy full-time it would have
made it a lot easier don't wait until
they're unbearable better help is
customized online therapy they offer
video phone and chat sessions with your
therapist
you know if you don't want to see
anybody on camera listen i don't blame
you you don't have to it's much more
affordable in person therapy and you can
start communicating with your therapist
in 48 hours
give it a try and see why over 2 million
people have used better help including
your uncle [__] joey all right
i worked at the lately dana and it was
phenomenal so do me a favor go to
betterhelp.com
diaz that's betterhelp.com
diaz
take control of your life and get the
help
you deserve better help i do my session
every monday 45 minutes in and out of
there i write down what's going on with
me during the week what [__]
things i got that i'm thinking about too
much and i just put on a piece of paper
when she comes on the screen i tell her
what my [__] problems are
and there goes the [__] week i feel a
lot better i've been doing it for about
six months
and i could feel the change i took a big
[__] weight off my shoulders you know
what i'm saying i also went to a goddamn
uh
at a meeting last week it was [__]
phenomenal
will i go back
i don't know i feel like a hypocrite i
still smoke dope i don't belong in there
but it's a [__] it's a wonder drug
marijuana i'm saying so i can't
if you're doing marijuana you really
can't go in there it's hypocritical
yeah i'm smoking a joint a day and
hitting a couple [__] things
on my little abx [__] tremendous
filter that they gave me i like it i
like it
it's nice
it's smooth
very [__] nice and i'll do this for a
couple weeks see if it affects my
breathing at the gym or whatever because
that's what happened last time i smoked
vapors
i felt that it would affect me i was
breathing differently and you know what
i don't right now i'm trying to [__]
uh
i'm sorry people right now i'm trying to
but hey listen at least we smoked a
little vaper pen we'll graduate you
never know i might pop into a [__] uh
you know i might have to do a little
salute i was just asking mike about his
holiday schedule
if the girls go away there'll be a
couple podcasts during the holidays and
toys and new year's and they could
[__] do a little something we could
[__] hit you with look at this
monster the [__] freeze pipe i love
this [__] i haven't even tried
this yet i've been messing around with
the bubbler because this is a [__]
monster i'm gonna save this for a
special occasion
because i love all this [__] and that's
it and that's that guys
i hope you had a fun phil [__] monday
i hope we covered some [__] listen
guys i'm just trying to get healthy and
have some [__] fun with you
guys
and crack some jokes on a monday morning
make your week a lot easier to check in
with you let you know i'm still slinging
dick and i'm still alive and kicking i
don't give a [__] about what's going on
in the world the party don't start the
uncle joey [__] gets there yet uh
sadly on twitter i tweeted out nice get
the party started for you with a [__]
uh laughing gas
that [__] run weed and some [__]
uh
and some of these edibles some abx 80
i'm gonna hold off on the abx capsules
till
after tapering how's that for you
[__] i'm gonna be a good boy
this week i got a couple [__] oils
and [__] like that i could substitute to
help me sleep do you know that last
night two nights ago saturday night
i went to bed at one in the morning i
went to bed like
10-1 after the ufc
do you know my [__] my wife woke me
up at 10 o'clock in the goddamn morning
wake up at all
not to piss not to do nothing no
sleeping pills no nothing
my little kikomo t
i hit the [__] syringe with like
maybe
yeah 200 milligrams you know i'm saying
i'm keeping a low
but i did get some kikimo uh
the mints that they have they don't do
nothing to you that two milligrams of
thc you need to eat 50 000 of those
things
but they got like five milligrams of cbn
so i don't eat them for the thc i just
put a handful in my mouth
for the cbn holy [__]
the last two friday night when i woke up
saturday morning i didn't know where i
was i was like i i woke up underneath
pillows and [__] you ever get your head
on the pillows when you wake up you
gotta throw pillows my arm got caught on
the sleep apnea hoes i'm like what the
[__] is this
i looked around i couldn't tell what
time it was it was like 7 50 in the
[__] morning and i'm like
holy [__]
i slept hard last night i'm getting a
whole new education on sleep those cbd
gummy melatonin
they knock you the [__] out too
uh i went to the health food store on
route 9 yesterday and that [__]
gave me a few edibles
and he was telling me to come back that
he's getting them on monday this heavy
duty cbn he goes dog as soon as i get
him
they leave
he goes people come in and buy him
because i got to call 10 people
so he goes let me he goes i'll give you
a call monday when they come and i'll
hold the container for you he goes to
just cbd
he goes heavy cbn
had the melatonin and he goes people are
begging for them
for me i got to take the like i went
back on the nyquil last night i did a
shot of nyquil not nyquil but the other
one they have now
nah it's not that you know that other
[__] worked
better drilled i ate those things like i
wouldn't even sneeze i haven't that was
the first time i sneezed that's the
first time my nose was congested in like
a month because for a month i'm hitting
[__] 75 milligrams of benadryl at
night for nappy noodle time after you
smoke a joint yeah yeah no it's [__]
good i'm taking care of myself guys you
know this has been a great adventure
moving here but uh
i love that term being a good friend to
yourself and taking care of yourself
i find myself doing [__] yoga at
night like i do a alberto crane put a
roll up there there he calls them
tactical fitness flows
they're three minutes i come back here
because you have to do them on the floor
i put knee pads on like a professional
[__] i do a bunch of little yoga
techniques and then i just do all these
stretches to stretch out
you know all the stuff he does it's like
a a lighter side of yoga there's still
front poses and you got to keep your
hands up and your hips straight and look
but you know what man it warms me up i'm
getting old and i like doing them i had
two jiu jitsu's last week and three
sessions at the gym
two sessions were a half hour
one session was an hour
i rode the bike last week i walked last
week i tell you i'm getting old but i'm
feeling good so
thank you for all the support do you
guys give me thank you
for the compliments
listen i'm looking healthier but i'm
getting older by the day i see pictures
of me and i go
i'm getting [__] old you know what
i'm saying i feel great my heart's in
great shape my attitude's great it's all
part to you guys for
having my back this year so i love you
[__]
with all my heart uh have a great
[__] monday
stay black i hope you enjoyed our little
tattoo day today i did i'm happy i'm set
to go i feel good and i feel confident
that we had this talk and i'll set you
out into the world on a [__] monday
morning and guess what they all gotta
suck your dick stay black i love you
[__] have a great monday tuesday
i'll be back wednesday
and that's it you [__] and now
for a word from our sponsors jack what's
happening you bad [__] thank
you very much for listening to the joint
today i was all over the place but i
don't give a [__] i'm just happy to be
feeling better we're gonna put this
[__] together but anyway the
joint is brought to you by freeze pipe
if you got someone on your holiday list
that likes to smoke reefer and see the
devil freezepipe.com
is for you i love my freeze pipe
i go with the bubbler it's a little
smaller nobody knows nothing i hide it
behind some pictures but listen smoking
weed doesn't have to hurt your lungs
with freeze pipe you get a nice cold hit
every goddamn time and here's how it
works the pipe comes with a detachable
chamber you freeze beforehand when
you're ready to rip the smoke passes
through the frozen part and it cools
down the smoke as you inhale it's just
like putting ice cubes in a bong but a
lot better it's non-toxic it freezes
faster than water and it stays frozen
longer freeze pipe cools down the smoke
by 100 degrees whether you hit a pipe
bubbler
bong or a dab they got it all guys if
you could smoke from it freeze pipe
makes it they don't have an apple i love
to smoke with a frog frozen apple i got
to talk to the people at freeze pipe but
listen do me a favor go to
freezepipe.com
take a look at the tremendous bonds they
have okay
if you like one pressing code joey
and you get 10 off your first order this
present is basically for yourself you're
taking care of yourself on this one
you're being a good friend to yourself
start with the bubble and knock your
[__] eyeball out
get the bung the pipe or the bubbler or
just get the bubbler and the pipe when
you get some more money but that's
freezepipe.com
and press order code joey to save ten
percent the sh the joint is also brought
to you by better help okay better help
want you to know the truth about some
stigmas around mental health i've been
with menthol uh with better health for
about six months now with dana and
they've been tremendous many people
think therapy is for so-called crazy
people but no it means that something it
means that something isn't wrong with
you it means that you recognize that
we're all humans that you have emotions
you know you don't know how to process
them therapy is a tool to utilize before
things get worse don't wait until
they're unbearable better help is
customized online therapy they offer
video phone even live chat sessions with
your therapist you don't have to see
anyone on camera if you don't want to
it's much more affordable than in person
it's a lot cheaper than in-person
therapy and you're going to get the same
results which is warmth and the ability
to just talk to somebody else and you
can start communicating within 48 hours
all right do me a favor give it a try
and see why over 2 million people have
used better health online therapy i'm
going to give you 10 off your first
month when you slap put in
betterhealth.com
diaz d-i-a-z that's betterhelp.com
diaz take control of your life and get
the help you deserve
with better help
all right and don't forget the joint is
brought to you by blue chew listen the
holidays are coming everybody wants a
present you're going to give the best
present
the best present you could give you know
what that is a hard dick
well you'd be having a white christmas
and new year's and valentine's if you
give her a good stabbing on christmas
you don't even need to worry about
valentine's that's where blue chew comes
in blue chew is an online service that
delivers the same active ingredients as
viagra and cialis at a fraction of the
cost you can take it any time day or
night the process is simple sign up at
bluetooth.com and talk to one the
licensed medical providers once you're
approved you'll receive your
prescription within days the best part
is it's all online no doctors visit no
pharmacy you're going to leave the house
no judgment it ships right to your door
in a discrete package not even your
mailman knows bluetooth tablets are made
in the usa just like you're [__] hard
on and it's way cheaper than a pharmacy
so do me a favor
it's time to perform it's the holidays
you got no time to [__] around blue chew
has a special deal for you try blue chew
free with promo code joey just pay five
dollars for fish ship shipping what
fishing
that's blue chew free with promo code
joey just pay five dollars for shipping
that's bluetooth.com
promo code joey to receive your first
month free i want to thank bluechu for
sponsoring to join i want to thank
bluechu i want to thank betterhelp and i
want to thank freezepipe but most
importantly i want to thank you [__]
savages on a monday morning i love you
with all my heart
stay black have a good week and we'll
see you [__] wednesday
the eighth tip top magoo stay black
[Music]
you